[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regarde dans la
glace avec tes Mines d'interrement
Ne laissez pas
allez
grimace gch mes derniers
des moments
pleurer sans
[Musique]
Moi quand je serai
Plus
pleurer pour
Moi quand je serai
[Musique]
Plus Je n'ai jamais
UE
de
patience j'ai toujours tout fait trop
TT j'aurais quand
[Musique]
mme pu
assister à la belle journée
nouveau trinquer sans
Moi quand je serai
Plus
eux
gars quand je serai
Plus ces
imbéciles tu ront
d'air vont vous faire du beau
temps c'est pas
facile comme dit brel de sang mourir Au
springemps chante sans
[Musique]
Moi quand je
Plus
chanter sans
Moi quand je serai
[Musique]
Plus
à toi le
moitié de mon
emme toi qui étais Plus que
tout je prends les
Sentiers de Cocagne
ce soir c'est la fin de
nous
enle
toi quand tchai
Plus
reviens
toi quand je serai
Plus ma vie s'en
elle va vers moi
quitte les remboursements j'ai rien
acheter plus j'ai un
plan
versez le
Suite Je vous prépare un
[Musique]
paradis
compter Sud
Moi quand je serai
Plus je serai
[Musique]
toujours quand je serai
Plus
[Musique]
Oh